assigned things are going in the right
direction in Spain health workers
celebrating the closure of a huge field
hospital installed at the end of March
in Madrid largest conference center but
although covered 19 infections are
falling these facilities will remain in
place in case there's a new outbreak
feel happy because we have won the first
battle of this great virus let's hope it
was the wall but if not we will return
here with more strength than before to
continue fighting Spain's had one of the
toughest lock downs but from this
weekend people will be allowed to leave
home for exercise on their own
of course the crisis is having a huge
financial effect here too
the government now says it expects the
economy to shrink by nine point two
percent this year
the only places in Europe with higher
official death tolls than Spain or Italy
and here in Britain following fierce
criticism over the relatively low
covered 19 testing levels the British
government has been increasing its
capacity it wants to put in place a
network to test track and trace people
with the virus as it looks to ease
lockdown restrictions and it's announced
it surpassed its target of a hundred
thousand tests a day for the end of
April testing is crucial to suppress the
virus I know from personal experience to
just how much people with symptoms want
to know if they've got the disease I
know that I did it helps remove the
worry it helps keep people safe and it
will help us to unlock the lockdown
meanwhile worrying statistics have
emerged suggesting coronavirus
disparities a new study in England says
the death rate among British black
Africans and British Pakistanis is more
than two and a half times that of the
white population and people in the
poorest parts of Britain are dying from
covered 19 a double the rate of people
in the richest areas on Friday the
French president explained that
traditional May Day events including
protests - weren't possible because of
coronavirus restrictions but he said the
spirit of workers solidarity was
stronger than ever
Gotham y gasset Ave its thanks to the
workers being celebrated today that our
nation is still standing it's thanks to
the work and dedication of our health
workers our security forces and our
military that we're saving so
many lives everyday there were
demonstrations elsewhere like this one
outside the Greek parliament in Athens
keeping their distance but determined to
keep up the pressure on the government
videos it there today the country's
working class despite protective
measures to minimize the spread of the
virus is here has a voice demands not to
be burdened by the crisis which is
accelerating because of the pandemic
Friday also marked the Catholic Church's
feast of st. Joseph the Worker Pope
Francis used a morning Mass in the
Vatican to say too many people globally
are either denied a fair wage or treated
like slaves in forced labor his audience
just a few nuns and priests his message
universal nadine barber al jazeera